you think you think you like you like
having sexual trans why yeah I have a to
me am I morally acceptable to trans
people that's based that's Bas I'm
Indian Muslim American Indian Muslim no
because she she started she started
kissing me and I start and yeah and she
ended up starting moaning she had like
kiss you but it was what does that mean
[Music]
big massive things happening today
ladies and
gentlemen all
right where the
oh uh Christmas Christmas is a joyous
time of year I
think I'm on the waiting
room
okay ladies and gentlemen
this is you introduced yourself you're
you're a queenan chatter right yeah I'm
a queenan chatter
yeah go ahead introduce your gentlemen
hello hello ladies and gentlemen boys
and girls my name is Lieutenant star
I've been on the internet for four and a
half years roughly and I'm considered a
reactionary populist in terms of my
politics basically I'm far right in
other words and economically center
right uh talk again really quick for me
okay hello my name is Lieutenant star
I've been on the internet for four and a
half years now I am center right
economically and socially farri
reactionary populist so to speak
reactionary populist what does that mean
when you say that so reactionary
populist is someone who believes in
let's just say the idea of reactionism
with the idea of the Common People of
populism so I think like Doug matriano
of the United States think someone like
Steve Bannon think someone like jar B
Jer bolsonaro in obviously Brazil that's
someone who that's what I believe
in I see give me one second I'm trying
to
uh let me ask Monro what are your
beliefs in
bud what are my give me one second I'll
tell you um yeah sure you can tell me
Maro take your time bud I'll take well
I'll take my time it's not dude Fuji
takes off working what
the oh is it because you don't can you
get a profile picture really quick or I
could get one for you no no no I got it
don't worry don't worry I got it I got
you I got you bud okay just SE for
profile
U yeah I got one I got one don't worry I
got one I got one okay see let see one
set yourself one I'll set myself one
don't worry don't worry I got I got a
good I got a good logo tell me if you
like it
mhm right let me know just get anything
I need something to show on the screen
just get literally anything I don't care
what it is all right let's go let's go I
got it I got it I got it for
you yeah I'm also on the Spectrum so
pardon me so you're on the Spectrum spum
yeah I'm on the autism spectrum but high
functioning high functioning so okay yes
I'm like I can do whatever the he
whatever is base here you'll get a black
screen it's pretty much uh all you can
get just something do you want a logo or
just a black screen is fine I I don't
care I just get a picture please I need
something to put on the screen literally
anything to put on the
screen set it set it as set something as
your Discord profile
picture all right I will I will we'll do
100% just
no n a no no I'm against
okay here we go
yes there we go got it done done boom
that's it we got it boom
booyah here we go that's it we're done
uh yeah that'll
work black screen what up look what up
ladies and gentlemen how we doing sorry
for taking so much time apologize for
that this is hold on let me
just let's see if I can
um I was really going to put the logo
button didn't have time because um I
wanted to give you some I wanted to
respect your
time you could you can you can yeah yeah
so whatever you'd like what we we can
debate about talk about whatever you
like is your stream
dude yeah give me uh give me a second
I'm GNA try to see I'm try to do
something take your time take your time
Moro take all the time you
need all the time
there we go all right I gave you a
profile picture so people can see when
you're talking this will
work yeah that'll work that's
fine all right you asked what I stand
for yeah what do you stand for what are
your beliefs Bud yeah I never forget the
tenants I swore to uphold I stay my
blade from the Flesh of the innocent I
hide in plag sight I never compromise
the Brotherhood
pretty cool so is that kind of like a is
that kind of like and correct me if I'm
wrong is that like a manosphere kind of
thing it's kind of like a manosphere
kind of thing
yeah cool manosphere is pretty cool I
mean I don't like Andrew Tate I mean I
used to like Andrew Tate but then he
ever said like uh trans banging is base
I'm like nah dude that that ain't cool
I'm not in defend I but I like
that you think you think you like you
like having sex with trans
yeah why is that feels
good why does it feel good it's
literally a because my penis goes into a
tight hole and then I come in
it let me let me tell you something Moro
okay if you're if there's a woman right
and she's got a dick how how is that
normal because like a guy a I'm I'm not
I never said it was normal I just said
it felt good when
I well why does it feel good because
don't you want to have a hold want to
have like a vagina so you could for a
woman so it could like it feels good
feels much better women have
assh why do you have I know but vaginas
women have vaginas they should have with
problem the pro no that's that's not a
problem I love I I love women with
vaginas I love women with [__] and
mouths that I can [__]
problem no I love that I love that so
what's the problem when I [__] a trans a
trans person in their ass then what then
a trans person the problem is is that
well what do they have is it a boy with
breast or is it a girl with decks which
one is it
both both well that's degenerate because
how are you going
to well reproducing is what really makes
Society grow and without that Society
will will fall
down I have a vasectomy am I morally
acceptable to [__] trans people
if you have a vasectomy just think about
it right just think how how [__] that
is you have a v v vasectomy which is
basically like you can't have kits so
what's the point even of having having
to [__]
someone because it feels good makes my
makes my [__]
come so it makes your [__] come but you
have a vasectomy so like how do you get
the pleasure you don't get the pleasure
dude because when you rub your penis it
feels
good well when you rub it but but like
you still have a vasectomy like what's
the of you having that pleasure if
you're not going to go forward with the
pleasure like for example I do go I go
forward I I come after I'm done rubbing
it yeah but that but what's the point
then you might as well then go for the
whole thing right might as well go them
for the whole thing might as well rip
rip
wrong you don't you don't you want to
just have a vasectomy rub your penis and
like not go for the whole thing yeah I
want to rub my penis and come in a trans
person's
[__] what is this are you Nick fan or
something
yeah yeah let me be very clear I've
never I've never watched Nick
ventes yeah Nick one this is a are you a
are you a queman fan or
something uh i' been on his chat a fan H
sort of not really oh you hate him you
hate
queman no I'm neutral I'm neutral I I
like him I don't care you know what he
says about blacks right what does he say
about blacks he's not a real big fan of
those Urban fell
is that's based that's based I'm Indian
Muslim American Indian
Muslim yep Indian Muslim
baby so I mean blacks to me I'm not
black I just had a profile picture
that's a black
screen you're yeah you're your profile
you're I'm showing a black screen on
that's what I'm showing on my end yeah I
know yeah yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not black I'm Indian Muslim you're
not black you're Indian Muslim
yeah I'm I'm on the far right I've been
on the far right for for a long time I'm
on the far
left on the far left yeah why well what
do you believe you like Hassan perer
Hassan dier never forget the tenants you
have sworn to uphold stay your blade
from the Flesh of the innocent hide in
play sight never compromise the
Brotherhood then out of the dark you
will come into the light and from the
light you will return to the
dark is this some Dark Souls reference
no that's what I that's what I believe
in that's what I
follow follow Hassan diker
where other men Finly blindly follow the
truth remember nothing is true where
other men are are limited by morality or
law remember everything is
permitted wow that's interesting that's
what I follow that's what I follow and
that's what I follow when I when I talk
when I think about morality and stuff so
when you try to tell me about morality I
think you're [__] I think you're gay
and [__] and you want to [__] trans
people well no that's stupid because
I've obviously gotten many woman
of nope you haven't
how come your balls are really big
because they're full of [__] because you
haven't came ever before in a woman
you've never had
sex no but I did I did have eex with you
had
eex with woman yeah
what yeah I
did all right so yeah oh yeah sure so
one time there was this woman who was
obviously like I'm not sure where she
was from I think she was from Britain
right uh we ended up having yeex on yubo
it's pretty fun
yubo yeah isn't that that pedophile
dating app it's not pedophile she was 18
how old are
you I'm 22 20 22 right now okay what how
how did you
have no because she she started she
started kissing me and I start and yeah
and she ended up starting moaning she
had like she had like was esex what does
that
mean esex you know I just got I just got
really excited you know but how was she
kissing
you she was like kissing me you know she
was like you know I'm not gonna show it
off here but she was kissing me she how
was she kissing you what does that
mean she was kissing me on the screen
she was kissing the
screen yeah she was kissing the screen
and I was like oh yeah that woman that's
hot that's hot
ba what happened
next and uh then I started uh I started
uh ejaculating
yeah yeah and that's it that's what I do
accept in real life with trans
women but trans women are not a real
woman no they they are you know why no
they're not why well their [__] feel
good enough so yeah they
are yeah but do they have a vagina they
don't don't care don't care don't care
got a vagina [__] a transwoman
missionary I grab on that thing like a
racing stick and I pretend I'm playing
fortza Horizon 4 Miata Miata
Miata you got but for the woman you got
to have like that boobs you gotta have
like the milk they they have tits they
have tits yeah but they have a dick you
know so they have problem I grab it and
I pretend that I'm playing Forza Horizon
Miata yeah Cherry BL cherry blossom
vinyl skin on the Miata forsa Horizon 4
vagina vagina tastes better I'm sorry
vagina tastes better when
the how do you know you're literally
swalling you're swalling testicles
you like you like SW testicles you
pedophile you like swing testicles
yep so pedop pedop ped gays people are
pedophiles you know that you I'm a
pedophile oh wow so you so so which one
do you like do you do do you like do you
like eight-year-old boys
both oh wow eight-year-old boys Mom Mom
I got we got to put you on the
registry
yeah yes that's that I would I would I
would I would notify your local school
immediately I don't go to
school yeah but I will I will notify the
public school and but I don't go to
school so I don't get why I would have
to talk to
him no I know you don't go to school but
I'm saying just confused because you're
telling me to notify the school but I
don't go to school so I don't know what
you
want no I'm saying you should notify the
police and have to register yourself but
I don't I'm not a police officer either
so I don't know why I have to talk to
those
people you don't have to talk this is a
really bad look what you're doing right
now I know this is a really bad look
what's a really bad look you're telling
me to talk to schools when I don't even
go to school I graduated I don't even go
to school anymore you're telling me to
go back there I don't even I don't even
go to school
anymore not telling you to go back to
school I'm just not a good luck buddy
bad Optics you're going to [__] up your
entire Online Career because of this
one all right take
care he left
[Laughter]
I think I just want to debate with a que
with a quean shedar
I literally went live just for that is
there anything else that's going on
that's all I wanted to
do wow awesome awesome
stuff crazy [__] happening where's the
cute and funny bug I they haven't gotten
back to
me wow Captain zor's live next
problem
wow now we need to go do the other
Towers in order to unlock the higher
tiers to get the ancient
cores so let us fly back over here and
see what's going on this is the average
quean video or viewer
yeah what is is he just watching the
[__]
debate this is so stupid this is so
stupid stupid
dude yes I'll I'll watch the quean
reaction to my
debate I don't have anything else to
cover I'll do this and then I'll I'll
look at YouTube drama or
something and then we'll look we'll find
something to cover we'll make it through
okay
ejaculating yeah yeah and that's it
that's I life with trans women but trans
women are not real women no they are you
know why no they're not well their feel
good enough so yeah they are yeah don't
care don't care don't care transform
missionary I grab on that thing like a
racing stick and I pretend I'm playing
fora Horizon 4 Miata
Miata is this what we've come to is this
what we [__] come to queman raid
thank you for the raid
queman is this
wow awesome crazy stuff let let's get
let's get YouTube drama loaded up for
what we're about YouTube drama yes there
better be some [__] here okay cuz if not
this is going to be [__] up this is
going to be [__] up what we're about
to do all right let's see but for the
woman you got to have like that boobs
you got to have like the milk they they
have tis they have tits but they have a
dick you know so they problem I grab it
and I pretend that I'm playing for for
Miata say Miata again Matata what do you
mean a Miata with a Hellcat swap cherry
blossom vinyl skin on the Miata for
Horizon 4ag vagina
sorag how do you know you're testicles
you like testicles you pedophile you
like SW testicles so pedop G people are
pedophiles you know that I'm a pedophile
wow so you so so which one you like like
do like eighty old boys
both oh wowy old boys I we got Jo
register yeah
yes I would I I would I would notify
your local school immediately I don't go
to school yeah but I
would I will notify the public school
and but I don't go to school so I don't
get why I have to talk to him I know you
don't go to school but I'm saying tell
me to notify the school but I don't go
to talk to those people this is crazy
this is a really bad look what you're
doing right now I know it's a really bad
look
you're telling me to talk to schools
when I don't even go to school I
graduated I don't even go to school
anymore you tell me to go back I don't
even I don't even go to school anymore
I'm tell you to go back to school I'm
just not good luck buddy bad Optics
you're gonna [__] up your entire Online
Career because of this one all right
take care he
left
wow all right
man this is so [__] calls himself a
pedophile and accuses the other person
of being bad Optics and they leave okay
I don't know how the [__] that worked
that's
crazy dud this is so okay hold on I got
to take my hoodie off it was really cold
but then my heater kicked on so I need
to [__] I need to remove some layers
give me a second